[Music]
everybody now is talking about the Pope
well one network has already taken an
advantage of the Pope's newfound
popularity and they developed this
brand-new show it's very exciting let's
take a look
two identical twin boys separated at
Birth one grew up in Brooklyn hey I'm
ready for Brooklyn and the other grew up
in Italy and became Pope I'm of the pump
when these two twins reunite
accidentally hey I look like you and I
look like you things get pretty crazy
[Music]
he's not the pump under the Pope
who's the Pope coming this fall
somewhere maybe hey bro let's go pick up
some chicks huh but I'm a celibate these
are driving me crazy
Wow
[Music]
that's an awful show it's a piece of
crap we should look at things before we
play them
that would mean coming in before the
show airs yeah cut into both of our now
time okay I feel like we all discovered
something together that was a piece of
[ __ ]
[Applause]
oh well our checks come either way
don't cheer that don't applaud that
that's awful we're gonna try harder next
time
sure we will